welcome back to Glamour of me joshing
host and today we're joined by Disney
star turned killer actress in the heat
you gave and her new album is just about
to drop Sabrina carpenter so how and
today are you gonna get your best makeup
artists on well you know uh many talents
no this is what I'm not completely sure
of yet but there's a first time for
everything
when I'm performing on stage I like to
go I like to go because wait when you're
on stage you're like this big and people
are really far away so you gotta you
gotta go and bring it gotta bring out
the drama so bring out that drama very
going a full glam look on you today I
hope you're ready I'm not so let's do it
we're going out extra extra extra extra
extra vibes extra on top of extra extra
one more time extra extra extra and the
first step in getting extra is this
fabulous eyeshadow palette yes yeah so I
I see this call under pressure color
that is also the name of a song that I
like and a very famous door in Russia
close your eyes though okay so I'm gonna
do this on the edges we're gonna smoke
this out of it just trust you know it's
all I'm trusting you back it's all about
trusting your fellow artists and I'm
gonna blend it in your crease up here I
don't think that this is the right
product to do that but the thing about
doing makeup in you know a short period
of time and you have to make do with
what you have I'm like I might even just
like use my fingers at one point but
I'll just get involved we're gonna add
some sparkle this is diamonds for
breakfast I love diamonds and we love
having them for breakfast breakfast is
the most important meal of the day close
your eyes you see this so this is super
pigmented which I like and I also like
the word pigmented so I just like saying
it a lot because it makes me sound like
a professional
but the pigmentation in this
is absolutely breathtaking so I'm just
breathtaking your big Ignace out I know
I think David Bowie no because you go
well that's not bad Larry not a bad look
the king of extra I'm gonna use this
revolution highlighter oh look at that
that's a revolution and shimmer I know
so I think to match with your sparkly
silver box I'm gonna do this like silver
ish type of highlighter wow that's again
very strong okay so if you ever just
want to look like a glazed doughnut
ahaha I recommend this palette highly
you also look like the Tin Man kind of
right now I think I'm not a little bit
of this color too because it kind of
looks like it kind of looks like a blush
in a sense and I just want you to I want
to warm up your face
so I look like a Krispy Kreme right now
ah not like a Krispy Kreme but more of
like like a unicorn just threw up oh
that's the lip yeah I would so I'm gonna
add some mascara right now okay so be
really careful okay this is everyone
shut up I feel tense okay this is
beautiful
Wow okay this is great you're really
naturally beautiful eyelashes I've got
the full babes don't try too flat with
me or gistic we're just accentuating
your natural beauty isn't
so that's kind of what men do a makeup
well about it's not really about me
changing you it's more just about you
expressing right in an extra light you
re yes because when you go out out out
babe on the town what's your usual
makeup vibe what's really fun for me to
like experiment with colors experiment
with different styles like different
sparkles but then I also like what I'm
not working I just like to keep it you
keep it real I keep it real organic this
is know God exists yeah okay so now into
your lips
what were you saying oh we're using the
Kylie lip
today the queen of lit cans are you like
an over liner you like Oh have we met
let's go IVA Lorelai we're over lining
okay I'm giving you a nice heart shape
with lips it's actually quite stunning
if you were gonna pitch now I know what
it's like when I'm talking with makeup
artists they're trying to do it actually
sucks this is great yeah are you talking
well I'm getting better you're getting
better my god
if you if you get a pitch you're out
makeup wipes sponsored by anybody
if you gonna pitch your album on the QVC
style fashion how do you pitch it
it's your everyday wanting to get pumped
and wanting to feel that Beyonce
confidence without actually being
Beyonce and wanting to feel
one-of-a-kind singular you are one
singular sensation you know it's really
hard to think of words when you're
focused on making you not look like a
clown okay does he look bad no one the
feedback okay thanks Rob if you could
just okay so this is the Matt thing that
we put on top we're really over line
today because who knows where you're
going tonight so now I think I'm gonna
do a little bit underneath don't it's
okay okay so open your eyes for me a pen
okay I feel like I'm taking a lot away
from this experience as should you
you're learning I'm learning we're all
running ok well that looks that looks
really bad okay well does it literally
look like a mermaid and unicorn that had
a baby I got more is more apparently
less is more
if you're gonna pick a song that sums up
this makeup leg what would it be
probably dancing queen by ABBA oh you
can dance you can jive watch that
blusher little wiener little Queen yes
okay so this is the reveal this feels
like I'm on like American Idol and I've
got to get the results I'm
to be Ryan Seacrest then right okay okay
you what's your best price Seacrest
impression well I kind of like a drag
queen he's not a very very very happy
night I don't like bring out a character
mmm what I like to do what would be your
ultimate drag queen name you can think
of one for me I don't know miss bring to
cop yes miss ring now dad now because
I'm gonna go out on the town with this
killer killer baby look what tips would
you give me for like annihilating the
competition on the dance floor I like to
go for like the worm in a nice one
can you cheer the web absolutely I
learned at a very young age it's a
staple I think that will get you free
life yeah I know it has my dimes that's
why I'm here today
what's your signature dance move oh the
[ __ ] drop and then if like I was gonna
meet a cute boys night and when it's
give them a good chop line what be good
chat line excuse hey do you like or I
could be like have you got a fetish for
doughnuts because I look dead glazed
good luck I want to see you use that
light on someone I want it to work oh I
will let you guys I will feedback for
more videos like this click here we can
put the button anywhere any way we want
like the hair described
[Music]